in the 1960s Glasgow was a dancing mad
city with crowds flocking to his many
ballrooms but for one young woman the
taxi ride home from a dance hall in
October 1969 but a man she just met was
destined to end in tragedy as the cab
made its way through the dark city
streets her fate was already sealed it
seemed she had been dancing with a
killer 13 o clock
[Music]
okay here we are again it's Tuesday and
it's episode and the 888 right 88 weeks
of this is it going by oh well yeah
about that fast time keeps on seven I'm
not sure we have like almost 2400
subscribers now it just grew by natural
means you know I feel like the movie
reviews have been a big help
yeah you know what I mean I do feel like
people are kind of discovering the show
through that although I don't know maybe
not maybe it's just the topics for do
yeah I think we need to shut down 13
o'clock at Menace that was kind of like
a waste and maybe we'll take that
material and just download directly into
the normal strain but that into a
different place I've been thinking about
doing that because you know how for our
hundredth episode we're gonna do like a
big super long kind of special edition
yeah and I thought as kind of an adjunct
to that that I would put all the 13
o'clock in minutes videos up around that
same time to is kind of like a hundredth
episode celebration so our hundredth
episode is gonna go up I think in July
July 17th or something like that so kind
of lookout for that I did start making
all those 13 o'clock in minutes videos
but they took such a long time and they
didn't really get a lot of hits and so I
was kind of like well man we should just
do movie reviews because they're much
easier yeah you know they are not as
graphics intensive right and there there
are more effective advertisement for the
yeah so I said well I'll just like
probably just close down that is an
extra Channel and just put them in the
regular stream but I'll do that right
around the July when we're doing our
hundredth episode now on this episode
yes since we've done like some
paranormal someone's all mystery stuff
like that I said why I want to get back
to doing true crime so what we're doing
today is we're talking about two British
serial killers who have never been
identified okay both of these serial
killers are going to be in volume two of
my book the faceless villain I'm going
to talk about both of them in there and
I mean these are like super weird cases
they're both from the 60s and these are
really two cases that I've always been
kind of fascinated by and maybe I get
the feeling that maybe they're not that
well-known in the u.s. all right so I
kind of want to talk
about those and while we're talking
about that I've been working hard as I
said on volume 2 of the faceless felon
yeah it's almost done actually not
really well from my point of view it is
you're like what well I'm more than
halfway down more than halfway that's
for sure but what I decided to do once I
got to the halfway point I was like okay
well I'm gonna go back and dig deeper
make sure I didn't like forget some big
[ __ ] like to put back in the first half
of the book and of course I found a
whole bunch of other [ __ ] because you
guys and I think I mentioned this before
you start looking into unsolved murders
there are so many many there are so many
and and I came up for a night with an
idea she said there's so many murders so
many murders and I said that should be
the name of a book good murders after
I'm done with the faceless villain
trilogy which I hope to have done by the
end of this year I might what I might do
is just make like The Clearing House
book of like all the [ __ ] I forgot to
the end these ones are the ones that I
couldn't put in before whatever wheels
it and I'll just call it so many murders
[Music]
well I'm like here's the like I had to
have some criteria like I didn't want to
put in ones that were like gang-related
or ones that were like you know robbery
someone was murdered in the course of a
robbery they were put in necessarily
like political assassinations no [ __ ]
like that that's any weird stuff like it
has to be mysterious or creepy you know
or random like I usually find ones
creepy that are like you know girl gets
off a bus and she's walking home and
she's disappears and they find her body
in a ditch like later on you know so I
kind of wanted to stay within that but
even within those parameters so many
it's like so I had to start you know I
made this humungous outline of like I
don't even know how many cases it is
it's it's a lot and I just have to go
through and I'm just taking out the ones
that don't have a huge amount of
information about them Rose I want to
have some you know something like
substantial to talk about if there's
only like three [ __ ] sentences about
some
this poor woman was found in her house
like stabbed 35 times you know that's
creepy
but you do it well I can't do anything
right now so I kind of wanted to stick
with stuff that there was a lot of
information about right so that should
be out like I said early summer I don't
know
you know the audiobook might take a
little bit longer that might be
midsummer but we'll see I've been
working on a lot the last few days and I
think I have the outline finalized so
I'm just gonna go and insert things and
like I said these two cases are in there
and I've already written about these two
but before we get to that let's first do
our shout outs last movie review was
phantasm so if you want to check that
out go and check that out if you haven't
this is popular it's popular movie yeah
popular review well I figured we had to
do that what I mean that's a good call
class I cannot believe how many hits the
black hole review has that must have
fallen into that little gap where it's
like a movie that a lot of people like
but not a lot of people have yet and
expect that because I kind of feel like
that happened with our logan's run kind
of thing right having vogue is rung of
eight thousand seven thousand yeah or
something because it was just something
I read that have cuz they showed it on
cable all the time like back in the day
yeah most the ones they have only have
like 30 not 200 300 maybe 400 yes but
like every now and then you get ones
like 7000 out of the blue 4000 it's just
yeah you never really know which one is
gonna do that I mean like I said I like
to kind of like our subscribers it took
forever to get to about a thousand subs
and then went from thousand to 2300
quickly I guess you just go to new
algorithms people share it yeah
obviously the main guys are sharing the
show thanks yeah thank you to everybody
that shared the show around and you know
recommended it to the record all these
comments you know on Facebook about how
they can't believe that we don't have
more subs that we have you know based on
the quality of the show you know we
can't control it it just you know so
telling you guys it just just you know
subs do what it does well you know we
just turn on the microphone back around
and it's make you want to listen to it
they're making listen just make
there they go honestly when we first
started the show I didn't think anyone
and you know some people have said that
the you know some people told us in
private that this is where their
favorite like paranormal / mystery
variety show I don't understand it you
know they got people that I look at the
show and I'm like people watch that got
like twenty three thousand subs and I
like and how well she does have boobs
yeah
there's some girls that just put a
camera on themselves you know in their
trailer somewhere and they got a hundred
twenty three thousand subs
oops - maybe actually I think maybe
actually just put like put a camera yeah
the problem is the problem you know and
tried to explain this to some people who
may have commented - why don't you guys
do it you know livestream the problem of
livestream is that the show you get from
us it's actually heavily edited well
we've cut out a lot of dead space yeah
because a lot of times were like oh [ __ ]
what we have to talk about next
because we're getting old and senile
sometimes I can't remember what word I
want to use or I forget a fact so I have
to go with event check it out right and
stuff like that you know it I like the
way that where our show is like
freewheeling right but that also entails
that sometimes I'm gonna forget [ __ ] and
I'm alright
like go back and fix it and you know
we're at the point now where we don't
want to put out misinformation or
disinformation so although we probably
still do yeah say something wait a
minute is that true does that just came
out of my mouth wait wait let's see if
that's true we see my memory is such a
vast wealth you know what I mean of
knowledge that sometimes I can't
remember what I remember I know how do I
know that where did that come from I
have a feeling that that's right yeah
and then I'll check it it is right yeah
but I can't tell you how I got that
information because you're like flows
into the ether man the pencil spear this
is crustal spear all the information is
going for the crustless but I think a
lot of people are like that says you hit
for you you know when you're older than
40 you know about your [ __ ] but you
can't remember how
how you know how you know it's just
stuff that you've record I mean
considering over my 45 years I've
probably read about 40 bajillion books
yeah so I'm gonna remember all kind of
facts and not have any idea how raw that
or even if I just made it up maybe we
read it I think you dreamt that you
don't know but yeah so most part our
show is accurate it's not perfect but
it's pretty I don't like I said don't
like don't kill me if it's not sometimes
I [ __ ] some [ __ ] up right that's just
how it goes yeah I mean all shows are
like that yeah anyways we we went off on
another tank yeah
go watch phantasm go well so if you want
to support the show go to our patreon
page at patreon.com slash 13 collect
podcasts for go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast WordPress comp yes yes
book a link in the sidebar
to a PayPal account also thank you to
our newest patron whose name is Anthony
thanks Anthony
Thank You Anthony Rock alright now
before we get into the main topic we're
gonna I have three little bit of news
stories they're not crime stories these
were just ones that I found I'll kind of
put in the news put in the news doing
this I should do it new so I was gonna
say you should do that every week now
doing that [ __ ] like like like dancing
you're not in the mood for singing like
maybe maybe I'll warn you when you're
the shower and yeah so these were just
three little news paragraphs that I
found on some [ __ ] news of the weird
site that I thought weren't entertaining
okay so this first one is from Alabama
oh [ __ ] yeah Alabama
okay and it happened on February 12th
now this woman named Beverly Harrison
who was a 62 year old woman her family
her relatives come over and they bring
her a present it's a ham okay which you
know
yeah that's pretty awesome southern
thing to do you give out foods yeah for
some reason I don't know if she was just
like [ __ ] that ham I'm allergic to him I
don't know what it was she waits til our
relatives leave then
takes the ham puts it in a trash can at
the hotel where she was living and set
it on fire what and then she took her
dog out for a walk without telling
anybody that there was a fire in this
garbage can and later on like I guess no
one noticed the ham exploded what no I'm
trying to put this yes as a result this
is what this is what the newberry says
she goes out to walk her dog cuz she's
just like I'm gonna it was it was kind
of like blowing up a car and walking
away from it in slow motion except it
was setting a hickey on fire and putting
in a trash can and then walking up
behind us around look yes so he says she
went on to walk her dog as a result and
this is a quote she was spared from
being a victim of the later explosion of
charred bits of ham that blew out the
front wall of the room I don't believe
this well when a nearby can of butane
fuel was ignited so there was a can of
fuel it was it did blow up it's just it
wasn't there was the source it was the
ham was blown up by the bike yes
so exploding hands oh okay I don't know
why well why well we need a woman what
what hotel was this do they name it it's
actually called the Bomar is it Bomar
okay I'm no more in in Athens Alabama
okay I'm picturing it as one of those
ones like like Dan Bell would go yeah
that's what I was picturing also which
is you know a single-story trashy hotel
there's a c-shaped and it goes around oh
yeah and the pool is a stagnant with
mosquitoes mosquitoes and as much
crackheads and rot kids probably what
happens they kick this woman out on our
own
you got a live-in motel we can't live
and they come in handy
here's your hand
all right then they leave right and
she's like sakyo ham and she doesn't you
know she throws it the garbage can and
then throws it he sets it on fire you
know I mean out of spite
well there was some gassed out of there
because some women just want to watch
the ham live I'm experienced with gas
okay she's actually in jail now for
arson no so she could face life in
prison if convicted
today one good fortune flowing up a hand
yeah arson or accident all right so that
was that was the first story now the
second story this took place on Easter
Sunday
this happened in Phoenix Phoenix mom
Sharon Dobbins was determined to get her
two teenagers
two teenage sons out of bed for Easter
services yeah on Sunday if this is gonna
be the Hearst what's neat was this again
but Arizona Phoenix Arizona over there
Jase yeah so one of them says nah I want
to go to church for ease too early I
want to sleep in yeah now what would a
regular mom do just kind of yell at them
you just you know just kind of get them
or just say [ __ ] it you can stay here
yeah okay that is not what this mom did
this mom tased his ass oh yeah yeah okay
I'm seeing it now what was it an actual
taser or was it a stun gun she had
evidently it's a Taser okay cuz a Taser
just grabbed a Taser let me explain this
to the audience
okay a Taser is a non-lethal weapon it's
much like a pistol it uses blanks to
fire needles out and then nipple has
some electrical leads on it goes india
hooks into you and when you pull the
trigger to shut this [ __ ] out of you
yeah now that's a Taser a stun gun just
looks like a television remote control
water with a couple prongs on the end of
it it's like a cattle prod I'm wondering
maybe she just hit him with a stun gun I
don't know it says tase
says taser that means she shouted what
he says specifically taser and it has a
capital T and everything okay and that's
what she did she was now the 16 year old
wasn't play in that called the cops
right and she was totally not even
embarrassed about it she's like the news
came
she told the news quote I said get up
it's Jesus's day yeah there we go
yeah so she got arrested for child abuse
yeah she says as Dobbins explained their
after quote all I was trying to do is
tell my kids to put God first okay
that's a good story yeah yeah so you
know it's discipline it's second only to
Florida I think for weird stories I just
you know this is to our UK listeners and
to our Australian listeners this is
[ __ ] America okay somebody tells you
did some [ __ ] you might get tased if you
don't do it you do we don't know balls
deep in insanity yeah we don't even know
we bring it yeah there's some crazy i
understanding you dealing with yeah all
right so the third and final story this
one is this one's actually kind of more
creepy than funny a 23 year old Selena
woman arrived at her home around 9:30
p.m. on Thursday March 29th to find that
the front door had been locked and
chained from the inside never a good
sign
she called the police who searched the
home and found no one there but two
hours later her ex-boyfriends legs
punched through the ceiling in her
living [ __ ] Tyler Bergkamp was his name
all right police arrested him and took
him to the Salina Regional Health Center
to recover from his fall he fell through
the buckets it would feel like a badass
another good ceiling I don't know I
don't know what he looked like well five
days later he left the hospital and
broke into another woman's house yeah
where he left his hospital gown
exchanging it for one of her t-shirts
and a pair of sneakers yeah
they don't say anything about pants so I
don't know it seems to me that if you're
trying to escape from the cops and you
break into somebody's house to take
their clothes it's probably less
conspicuous to be running around in a
hospital gown than it is to be running
around in a woman's t-shirt and women's
shoes with no pants up yeah I'm just
saying maybe he did that for some reason
this case kind of reminds me of another
case that happened here in the United
States this is probably 10-15 years back
they had some boy this isn't one of the
more rural areas what came up missing
they look for him look from there could
find he was a teenager
how about 16 17 18 around that time well
a few miles from where he lived there
was a house had been sitting vacant for
a long time like five six years somebody
bought and they were in that house for
months winter came they went to go make
a fire in a fireplace and all the smoke
started filling up the house oh they put
the fire out you know they were trying
to figure out why the chimney wasn't
ventilating there he was that missing
boy stuck in a chimney dead long time
it's like that story from gremlins that
you heard address Epis am I getting
stuck yeah you know they figured what
happened was when that house was
abandoned he tried to get into it like
[ __ ] man down chimney got stuck and was
alive in there for a long time well yeah
I get to the guys Darby no starvation
but the thirst progress seven days yeah
couldn't go couldn't go back up couldn't
get back down just don't ever try to
break into a house that's the chimney
all of the story if you're gonna break
into a house
glass breaking glass protip yeah it's
not as loud as you think it is
now you have a method of egress right
you're not gonna get stuck in wrong and
Jimmy
yeah so that's horrible so yeah this guy
obviously they did catch him later on he
faces a number of charges and one of
which is being a dumbass which isn't
illegal but it probably should be all
right so now let's get to the main topic
now that we're [ __ ] 20 minutes into
this [ __ ] not the show
no it's an extra-long show yeah that's
what we do we went out we go over a
couple times and like I said I actually
well I did get a couple of complaints
that like over 18 minutes in and we
still haven't gotten to the main time on
the last one but I just like deleted I'm
gonna shut up now they go well and
honestly on the last episode I think it
was 26 minutes in before we started
talking about the main topic I put a
note in the description that yeah hey if
you just want to hear about poorly
rectory right go to 26 minutes cuz ever
I started talking about it before that
we were like went off on our kind of let
me say something to the artists we value
our audience okay but we're gonna do the
show the way we feel like doing it at
the time yeah it is no like I said if we
got 20 at least 23 24 hundred subs right
now yeah we can't make them all happy
yeah there's always gonna be a few
people that said I don't like why I
don't like that general people liked the
show
yeah yeah so anyway let's get to the
main thing now the first serial killer
that I want to talk about is not Jack
the Ripper but Jack the stripper oh [ __ ]
this is actually kind of a infamous
unsolved serial murder series they think
he started killing in 1959 alright
although that they're not really sure if
it's the same guy but this is also known
as the hammersmith nude murders alright
and they never caught this guy there's
not really much of an idea who could
have done it so let's kind of lay out
the thing now the first victim that I
think might have been him this happened
in 1959 and the woman's name was
Elizabeth fig she was 21 years old she
was a prostitute this is why they called
him Jack the stripper because he mainly
targeted prostitutes same as Jack the
Ripper dead and it was in London right
around the Thames the prostitutes
no but no they call him Jack the
stripper because most of the bodies were
found naked
oh okay stinking clothes that's why got
ya he killed prostitutes and stripped
them there you go so now it's making
sense yeah okay so this is a fig 21
years old she was from Cheshire
originally they found her dead on a tow
path on the banks of the River Thames On
June 17 1959 she had been strangled her
clothes she wasn't completely naked but
she'd been the her top was torn open so
that [ __ ] her breasts were exposed her
shoes and underwear we're missing all of
her personal belongings were gone now
they thought at the time that maybe she
had been picked up by a client and that
she had taken off her underwear and
shoes in the car you know in the course
of the transaction let's call it that we
call a trick yeah and he subsequently
killed her and dumped her off so they
figured that she had probably been
killed between midnight and 2:00 a.m.
and when they were canvassing the
neighborhood they found that a couple
who owned a nearby pub said they saw a
car or they saw headlights of a car at a
little past midnight and what sounded
like a woman screaming although they
didn't really investigate because I
guess that happens a lot around there I
don't know okay so this they're not sure
if this was the same guy it might have
been but it was four years before
another murder would happen that they
thought was a serial killer but they
think maybe that was his kind of early
one of his early crimes the next one
that was similar didn't take place until
November 8th 1963 that's when the body
was found
now there were some workers and they
were in a dump in London on the south
side of the Thames they found a really
decomposed body buried under two feet of
garbage
she was totally naked except for one
nylon stocking that had been rolled down
to her ankle almost like somebody did it
on purpose now the truck that had found
the body had actually cut her head off
they said several of her teeth were gone
too but they're not really sure if the
truck did that or if the killer did that
right but they're pretty sure that the
truck cut the head off now they're not
sure how she was killed although they
could tell from you know the hyoid bone
that probably she had been strangled
just like the first lady in 1959 had
been she was actually not identified at
first she wasn't identified until almost
20 days later when they matched her
fingerprints with ones that were already
on file so then they found out that this
woman was also a prostitute she was 22
years old and her name was Gwyneth Reese
she was a from Wales originally and she
also worked under several different
aliases which a lot of them did at the
time right so this one they're not sure
if this was Jack the stripper either but
it kind of sounds like it was especially
the thing with the stocking and
everything because a lot of the later
ones had that same detail now she had
last been seen alive on September 29th
and she was seen getting into a car that
witnesses thought was a Ford Zephyr or a
Ford zodiac now interestingly one of her
pimps they don't really call them pimps
they just they were somebody that
procured clients for them yes but he had
a Ford Zephyr all right and when they
searched his car they found some of when
it's blood in it but he admitted to
beating her up on several occasions his
name was Cornelius Whitehead so they
couldn't really but he said you know I
did beat her up a few times you know how
she was a hooker when he was trying to
get money out of her or whatever but he
says he didn't kill her right and they
couldn't prove it you know it's a
process called putting your pimp hand
down sometimes a pimp has to unholster
his 45 caliber
do you know what would be really funny
if I took you doing that voice yes and
put it over like an old 50 style low
training
yes like the ones they do on shorts on
every question and you can you could
have like the little kind of little pimp
cartoon sure it's like teaching you how
to be a pimp yeah it's a given but 1956
yeah so they couldn't really prove that
he was the killer there were a couple
other suspects Reggie and Ronnie Kray
who were actually very famous gangsters
and they okay at that time they were
suspected they were questioned but they
wouldn't say anything they couldn't get
anything out of him one of their
associates George Dixon was also
questioned they couldn't didn't have
enough to hold him either and I mean for
this murder I have to say I think a lot
of times maybe in the u.s. when a
prostitute gets murdered
I don't know how stringently they
investing in I mean maybe they do maybe
they don't I guess it depends on the
jurisdiction yeah
but in this case when winneth Reese was
killed even though she was a prostitute
I mean they didn't [ __ ] around they had
around thousands of people they like
just you know they went all out right
now it's not anything against the United
States just as some of these
jurisdictions are heavily overworked
right they you know there are murders
happening right now they gotta worry
about yeah yeah and we were talking
about this yesterday because I was
talking about how and this is something
that I only just discovered yesterday
when I was researching other cases to
put in my book do you know back in 1965
when the FBI first started keeping these
types of records the percentage of
murders that were cleared meaning
someone was arrested and put on trial I
don't know if it necessarily means the
person was convicted or not but it means
that someone was arrested and put on
trial for the murder that rate was 90%
in 1965
yeah in 2012 it was 64% so despite all
of the forensic technology that we have
at our disposal now for some reason
there are way more unsolved lines right
and they seem like they're piling up
right it seems like if they don't solve
something in the first 24 hours
[Music]
hours then it's pretty much not going to
get solved although there are a handful
of cases ones that were solved many many
years later which you know that's yes
and everything a lot of times what
happens in the criminal world is that
somebody gets knocked off there are no
suspects case goes cold if they don't
have a suspect within 48 hours chances
are that's a wrap then four or five
years later somebody gets pinched or
they get squeezed and they end up in
jail or prison for a lesser crime they
know who killed that person and they say
look cops I'll tell you who committed
that murder four years ago if you let me
out then I go back and you know they get
that guy that's how a lot of those
unsolved letters are actually solved
their solve what's called prison
snitches yeah well the problem to that I
came across research in cases
particularly in these cases is because
these people these killers are targeting
just random women and some of them in
the case of Jack the stripper he was
targeting marginalized women prostitutes
you don't know I mean they have so many
clients they have so many associates
there's really you know where do you
start right and I think that happened
with a lot of the cases that I was
researching from the book to even ones
that weren't necessarily serial killers
but I mean you know if there's just some
ten-year-old girl walking down the
street or riding her bike to the store
one day and somebody just put crabs or
puts her in a car and kills her and
throws her ditch there's no relationship
between him and huh
yeah so where do they begin well you
know there's this weird perception of
the law and order which sometimes really
isn't there I get to say the criminal
justice system and law enforcement
aren't as effective as people and to
believe it is and though I should say
that even though the rates of unsolved
murders is higher the actual number of
murders has gone lower it has actually
gone down since then
and we were talking about that earlier I
think it's environmental it's in that
might be one of my theories has to do
with the leaded fuel letting fuel came
out for a while and I think I think cars
were blowing led out of the exhaust
pipes yeah and it collected up inside
cities over the decades and I think
people were inhaling it and you know
that lead causes people to do crazy [ __ ]
including be violent
well let it fuel they started facing out
in the 80s and it seems like maybe the
lid is blowing away I don't know that's
just my crazy idea because that is the
crime rate started going precipitously
downward yeah at least in the u.s. maybe
all that built-up lead particles are
being you know washed away through by
rains and it's possible I suppose it
might be a contributing factor it will
die off and new people are born and
they're not being is they're not as
poisoned you know yeah from lead because
they weren't they didn't live in a high
lead environment yeah that's just what
else is not a stinking yeah and it's
always seems to be in or in a urban
environment to where where the traffic
is yeah you know I mean have you had the
story and say you know these ancient
Romans they did crazy [ __ ] because lead
poisoning you know they were eating off
of that place they have lead pipes yeah
I think they said that has led pipe so I
know that they were eaten off of lead
silverware yeah and that maybe that's
driving them crazy but you know they
don't ever mention leaded fuel that was
being burned at that time yeah wasn't a
good idea to put that in fuel I know it
wasn't because those valves were quiet
quieter in a car but not a good idea
no anyway so Gwyneth Rees even though it
kind of seemed like maybe her pimp tin
at Cornelius Wayne head now she had an
associate who was also prostitute her
name is Brenda Mia and she said you know
I saw Gwyneth getting into the car like
on the last day she was seen and she was
like that is not Cornelius's car yeah so
now they're thinking like I said Gwyneth
Rees she was the second murder and
they're not she's usually considered a
possible jack the shipper they're not
entirely sure if it was him or if it was
someone else but the next one that one
was definitely that's definitely
attributed to Jack the Ripper this
happened on February 2nd there were two
brothers George and Douglas Kapaun I
guess
is how you pronounce it they were
members of the Corinthian sailing club
and they were getting ready for a boat
race on the Thames and they you know
we're getting their boat ready and then
they saw a woman's body kind of lying
half in and a half out of the water on
the banks of the Thames and this victim
also found completely naked except for
her nylons rolled down to her ankles so
they took the body out of the river and
she had she also had missing teeth she
had bruising around her jaw they said
that could have been from falling or she
could have been assaulted at some
earlier date now the missing teeth were
busted out from punches or were they
just missing yeah they're not real sure
because like I said
Gweneth Rhys the one that was found in
the garbage pile her teeth were missing
too but they're not sure if the truck
did that or if the killer did that
injustice so yeah that's another thing
she'd eaten a full meal shortly before
her death she had died probably about 2
to 7 days before her remains were
discovered no trace of alcohol or drugs
in the system now this was an
interesting thing though there was fluid
in her lungs like watering her lungs
that was consistent with drowning so
they were kind of like maybe it was an
accident
however then they looked down in her
throat and found a pair of her own semen
stained underwear yeah
crammed down her throat so obviously she
had not drowned even though you know
there was enough water in her lungs
yeah what he did was he beat her
senseless he thought that she was dead
he shoved that down her throat threw her
in the water and then she went and she
drowned but she was you know unconscious
yeah so this was another woman they
didn't know who it was straightaway they
fingerprinted her and then they matched
her to a woman named Hannah Taillefer
she was 31 years old also a prostitute
and a petty criminal and she was
originally from Northumberland now the
first investigation into this they
actually questioned her common-law
husband who was known as either William
Ewing or Alan Lynch they've been living
together for about eight years he said
that the last time he saw her was on
January 24th at 9:00 p.m. and he said
she went out they had a flat and she
went out and she was going to work now
he said I didn't know
was a prostitute even though they've
look together great years she said I
thought she just worked the night shift
at some cafe
oh she was working the night yes all
right yeah but so I don't know if he
just made that up or whatever but he
said oh I always thought she just had a
job in an all-night cafe I didn't know
she was a prostitute he says that was
the last time you saw her January 24th
however a bunch of other witnesses came
forward and said that they saw her
between January 24th and February 1st
which was the day before her body was
found the people that lives downstairs
from Allen Lynch and Hannah Telford said
that on February 1st like early morning
that they had heard footsteps on the
stairs and the sound of a woman
screaming
although Allen Lynch says that's
[ __ ] because there were no women in
the house on that date now they had
another acquaintance of theirs named
Thomas trice and he said that Allen
Lynch gave him a pair of shoes and some
articles of clothing that were Hanna's
and he handed them to him and he said
get rid of these so Thomas trace handed
them over to the cops and he said when
they got the shoes they were kind of
muddy yeah but they were unable to match
the mud to the mud on the tens where the
Barros found so they weren't real sure
so this could have been her husband but
I don't know right
so they said because they said that he
seemed really upset that she was dead
and he could operated and he did
lie-detector tests and all that kind of
[ __ ] he cooperated with Scotland you
already answered all the questions and
stuff like that so same kind of thing
there's a huge thousands of people
interrogated they searched the area
there was a place called Dukes meadows
they think that was where her body got
dumped several weeks later on February
19th a Bluecoat that was later
identified as Hannah's was found caught
in the propeller of a boat on the Thames
so this was the same coat that she had
been seen wearing the last time she was
seen alive so like I said it's weird
because the inquest even though she had
underwear stuffed in her throat yeah
there were still some arguing at the
coroner's inquest that maybe it was an
accident or may
she committed suicide or something like
that so they the coroner's jury actually
ended up leaving the verdict open that's
which I thought was bizarre cuz
obviously it was a murder sounds like
the cops didn't want an unsolved murder
maybe not and you know and it's just
weird because then later on that year
there would be you know another two
women turning up dead in the same you
know method and actually will we're
gonna take a break right now and I'll
get into that when we come back so we
will be back in just a couple of minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I'm we're back during the break I
realized that when I was talking about
Hannah Hannah Sanford's murder I think I
said that it was February 1964 it's
actually February 1963
oh so you know don't hate I was just
looking at the wrong thing okay
so then comes April of 1963 and there's
two more women turn up dead first one
April 8 26 year old Irene Lockwood they
found her also on the banks of the
Thames
she was found right in between where
Elizabeth fig had been found in 1959 and
where Hannah Telford was found in
February of 1963 now same deal with
Irene Locke Lockwood as Hannah Telford
she was also found naked no obvious
fatal wounds she had a deep cut on her
shoulder but they think that might have
happened after she died like from a boat
propeller there were traces of semen
found in her mouth and her vagina but it
did not appear that she'd been sexually
assaulted so that might have just been
her from her last client or whatever and
also same deal it was determined that
her cause of death was drowning although
they thought that she was probably
unconscious when she was put into the
river I don't think there was anything
stuffed into her mouth or anything like
that it was almost like somebody knocked
her out and then threw her in there and
she drank choked her out yeah in there
she was also four months pregnant ooh
the last time she had seen she was she
was seen at a pub in Chiswick at around
8:00 p.m. on the evening of April 7 so
that was like the night before she was
found and you know she was pretty much
the same profile as the other victims
she was originally from Nottingham and
worked as a prostitute petty thief since
she was 19 she had had a son in 1958 but
she had given him away the interesting
thing about Irene
was that about a year before she was
murdered she had been friends with this
other prostitute who was named Vicky
Pender now Vicky Pender was found
murdered in Islington in March of 1963
the main suspect in that murder was a
guy named Colin Fisher who was kind of
big on the underground pornography type
of trade now he knew Vicky Pender
obviously that's why he murdered her he
also knew I renew her as Sandra so Irene
Lockwood I think from what I've read
about this case kind of blew Colin
Fisher's alibi because he said oh well
when Vicki Pender got murdered I was
living with Irene Lockwood and Irene
Lockwood said no you weren't
[ __ ]
huh so you know so then Vicky turned up
dead and then like I said I rain turned
up dead so Colin Fisher they're not
really sure about that he was actually
convicted of Vicky Pender's murder so he
was spent life in prison and he died in
prison now another person that they were
looking at then Irene Lockwood's murder
they were looking through her apartment
and they found a purse and it had a
business card that had a phone number on
it and it had the name Kenny
so they actually traced this back to a
57 year old guy named Kenneth Archibald
and he was a handyman at this Tennis
Club and at first he said no I don't
know that woman but then somebody else
that works the clubs like yeah you knew
it's like she comes to parties here all
the time and you know her so then later
on like there would be more [ __ ] with
him later on but before that happened
there was another murder so this other
prostitute named Helen barthélemy she
was 22 and they found her on April 24th
now they didn't find her in the Thames
this time she was actually in an alley
not that far from the river she had also
been strangled you know very similar to
Elizabeth fig and Gwyneth Rees from 1959
and 1963 but the interesting thing about
her body was that they found little
chips of automotive paint on the body
and if they thought that this had come
from like a workplace or a factory and
that's probably where the killer was
keeping the bodies before
was dumping them now before they kind of
look too much into that here comes
Kenneth Archibald he wanders into
drunkenly into a police station in
Notting Hill and he says I killed
Irene Lockwood I pushed her into the
river so they arrested him and they put
him on trial in June of 1964 but when
they got him on the stand he said no I
didn't do that I just made that up I was
drunk and everything like that so he
enters a plea of not guilty so you know
they do the investigation they're like
well there's really no other than this
business card that she had in her purse
there's no physical evidence tying him
to the murder I mean rather than him
just walking drunk asin's and Notting
Hill and saying yeah I killed her so
they had to let him go
now three weeks after that they found
another naked body of another prostitute
she was 30 years old her name was Mary
Fleming they found her in a sitting
position outside of a garage in Chiswick
she had last been seen on July 11th
though her body wasn't found till the
14th
she was also strangled she also had
flakes of car paint on her skin so at
this point all of these women turning up
dead even though that a lot of them have
other kind of promising suspects you
know the method in which they're all
killed the method in which they're all
found they're all found pretty much in a
similar location a lot of them are naked
with their nylons rolled down and stuff
like that so they kind of think this is
probably one guy this is a serial killer
now the last one that they think that he
killed that happened on February 16 1965
and this was another prostitute her name
was Bridget O'Hara she was 28 years old
and she was actually found in a storage
shed behind this thing called the Haren
Trading Estate now when they she was
also strangled and she had paint flecks
on her skin now the paint flakes matched
some paint flakes they found inside this
building hmm so they're determining if
this is a serial killer
this is either where he works or this is
where he's storing the body before
bodies before dumping them in the river
because this was like this kind of
industrial automotive paint so since
they had kind of narrowed that down and
that's where the paint is coming from
they focused in on this one particular
suspect
his name was Mungo big John Ireland
because why not okay so he was a
Scottish fella and he worked at the
Heron Trading Estate so they're like
well it's got to be him because you know
obviously they're trying to build a case
against him he's Jack the Ripper but
less than a month after Bridget O'Hara's
body was found Mungo Ireland committed
suicide by us fixing himself it's this
ex fixating himself with carbon monoxide
in his car huh March the 3rd he died he
left a note for his wife yeah and part
of it said I can't stick it any longer
to save you and the police looking for
me I'll be in the garage huh and he's
dead so they don't know if he was Jack
the Ripper or not although the
automotive paint would kind of suggest
yeah maybe although it's weird because
even though to me he seems like the most
likely suspect when you're doing
searches for Jack the stripper or the
hammersmith nude murders as they're also
called the main suspect that comes up is
this guy in Freddy Mills who was like a
pretty famous boxer at the time
apparently in the kind of gangster
British criminal underworld hmm they
were pretty sure that Freddy Mills was
Jack the Ripper they said it was it was
like kind of a known quantity or he
thought he was like kind of a sexual
sadist and so among the criminal
underground they're saying we thought it
was this boxer right now in July of 1965
Mills also died they think it was
suicide it was self-inflicted gunshot
wound right although it might have been
an execution no not entirely sure they
think it might be a service when [ __ ]
asphyxiated himself did the murder stop
yeah that's pretty but like I said
they're not sure they think Bridgette
Amir was the last one right these guys
don't stop until they die Bret were cut
our cashiers so I would say the probably
[ __ ] so yeah [ __ ] died and but like I
said Freddy Mills who was another main
suspect he also died later on there's
over sure there but I think it was a
so yeah and you know there were some
other suspects - there were um there's
this book that came out called Jack of
jumps by David Seabrook and he thought
that or at least he said in the book
that a lot of senior investigators at
the time thought the killer was actually
a cop that it was a police detective
named Andrew John push way although I'm
not really entirely sure I haven't read
the book I'm not entirely sure why
people thought that it was him I mean he
had been arrested but for love Breaking
and Entering like little right it wasn't
murder or anything to me it sounds like
something really mundane yeah not so
much a Gary Ridgway type guy yeah but
just some Doug that liked hookers they
want to pay yeah beat him to death you
know got off on that strip the clothes
off them throw them and the clothes in
the water you know nothing complicated
really probably not one of the other
main suspects that is usually put
forward is this guy Harold Jones he was
from Wales now he was actually convicted
in 1921 when he was 15 years old of
killing two little girls and he got a
life sentence but he only served 20
years and then he got released some good
behavior in this case yes so he actually
they thought that he did move to London
in 1947 with his wife and daughter so he
was probably living there at the time
the hammersmith nude murders were kind
of similar to the ones that he had done
he hadn't raped the girls and the
murders were not particularly violent
right just like these weren't these
girls weren't stabbed they weren't
beaten to death or anything they're
usually just strangled or drowned or
something like I'm not that that's not
horrible and I thought it's known right
but I'm just saying you know they
weren't like cut up or anything like
that like Jack the Ripper would have
done so they thought that was kind of
significant but like I said they're not
sure if he was involved either so to
this day the identity of Jack the
stripper is unknown and it is unknown if
the first two murders of Gwyneth Reese
and a Elizabeth fig were committed by
the same guy if they were committed like
I said these were all prostitutes out of
the - it could have been any number of
people right out of the - you talk to
most about price
logo that does seem like I mean the
paint seems kind of that being damming
that would be enough to get a conviction
in the United States yeah and the fact
that he killed himself after he didn't
confess to the murders in the letter or
anything like that
but the fact that two or three of the
victims were found with this particular
paint on their skin you thought they
were gonna maybe he worked there he saw
used that really does kind of seem he
thought he was done for suspicious yeah
he killed himself to save face
I find I'm kind of leaning toward that
as well because that really does seem
like the most damning piece of evidence
in that case now this next one this guy
probably one of Scotland's best-known
serial killers still unknown
he killed as far as they know unless
it's who they think it might be he only
killed three women now these women were
not prostitutes the weird thing about
this guy though is that all three of the
women were taken from the same neck love
huh at different times okay so this is
the case of Bible John okay and you'll
know why they didn't start calling him
that until the third murder and I'll
tell you right so this actually the this
case began in February of 1968 this
happened in Glasgow Scotland now
apparently in the late 60s in Glasgow a
whole bunch of like dance halls and
night clubs opened and I saw a
documentary about it where they were
saying Glasgow went dance mad so
February 1916 there's this 25 year old
nurse her name is Patricia docker and
she and her husband Alex had just split
up she had moved back in with her
parents she had four year old kid but
she left him with the sitter one night
she's like I'm gonna go out dancing so
she told her parents that this was going
to be a problem later on she told her
parents that she was going to a place
called the majestic ballroom which was
kind of the more upscale you know dance
hall in the area but she actually ended
up going to the Barrow Lance ballroom
which was a lot more downmarket
they say they're not really sure if she
went to the majestic first and then
what's the
she was just intending to go to Berlin's
old but she used to tell her parents no
man don't go to that [ __ ] place yeah
but that's where actually where she went
she evidently met someone there that
killed her because the next morning
which was February 23rd there's a guy
named Morris Goodman and he's cutting
through a back alley on his way to work
and he finds the naked dead body of
Patricia docker severely beaten raped
strangled with her own stockings
she was found this was the saddest part
to me her body was found less than a
hundred yards from her parents house
damn yeah like in an alley they never
found her clothes they found one shoe
which we was still wearing here was
something and this was gonna be kind of
a hallmark of all of these Bible John
murders they found they were all on
their period weird yeah and they would
also like he would put like a pad you
know like a maxi pad or something like
on the body or buy it weird yeah it's
like like it was a fetish or something
yeah so they found I already know well
that's what I mean unless I nice
electabuzz is totally random totally
coincidence maybe yeah I don't know it's
just really super weird that's what I
always thought too it's like what did
you ask them or something that seems a
little creepy but yeah so they did find
a maxi pad like near the body another
thing that would that would happen a lot
was that the he would take their purses
and he would dump all the [ __ ] out like
all and scattered all around but not
really take anything I want to say was
in there I guess yeah her like or like
he would take a few things and that's it
they dredged the river cart which was
nearby they did find a bracelet
belonging to her and they found the
actual purse but you know that was
pretty much it they never found her in
clothes or anything like that now
because Patricia
had told her parents that she was going
to the majestic ballroom they actually
lost three days of investigation because
they were investigating in that place
and said she was in there her Burlinson
yeah she wasn't there and it didn't help
that like somebody to come where we go
oh yeah I totally danced with her the
majestic that night before coming out
later and being like oh maybe that was
another night
right right so you know they kind of
lost a lot of information because of
that you know she wasn't going out
expecting to get killed she's right
was her so they really had nothing much
to go on now a few people said that they
had seen her at the barrel lands that
night they said yeah she was dancing on
the feet of her guys she was you know
having a good time they said one of the
guys had bread hair which was kind of
significant but you know that was too
big and they're like okay well right so
then nothing happens for a little while
the next thing that happened was August
15th 1969 an almost the exact same
situation
Jemima MacDonald she was 32 years old
she had also recently separated from her
husband and she was gonna go dance at
the barrel Lance had left the kid buu
kids with the sitter and she's going to
the barrel and so she was seen at this
particular dance hall around midnight
she left in a company of a tall thin
well-dressed man with red hair and
subsequently disappeared
the following day her sister whose name
was Margaret she starts hearing rumors
around the neighborhood that some kids
have been at some like abandoned
building or something like that and
they're talking about a body and so
Margaret's kinda like well jeez I
haven't heard from Jemima for a day or
two yeah I'm gonna go to that abandoned
building to check it out yeah so she
goes there and finds her sister's body
- Wow which I would think you would call
the cops but maybe she didn't think
anything she thought they were maybe the
ocean yeah yeah they thought it was just
[ __ ] like it was stupid kids stories
so she found her sister's body in this
abandoned building
so also like the previous victim had
also been raped beaten and strangled
with her own stockings although she was
not found naked she was found fully
clothed
she was also on her period and also same
thing with her purse being dumped out
and scattered all around
now the third murder happened on
Halloween night 1969 and this was 29
year old Helen Puttock now her and her
sister whose name is gene mcLaughlin
they went dancing at the Berlin's
ballroom now even though these murders
had taken place in Glasgow so you
the nightclub scene had kind of
diminished a little bit obviously
because women didn't really wanna go out
by themselves it's weird to run around
but you know they were still like oh
it'll be okay they were together so the
two of them went out and what ended up
happening and this was actually where
they got most of the information of why
they ended up calling him Bible John
which I'll get to in a minute so the two
sisters are at the barrel lands they
meet two guys at the bar they both say
their name is John one of them says he's
from Castle milk which is a district and
I believe it's in the southern part of
the south of Glasgow the other one
didn't say where he was from so the four
of them kind of drank and danced and
have a good time they all left as a
group now the guy that said he was from
Castle milk he's like well I got a state
I gotta go get a bus so he goes to get a
bus home now the other three the two
sisters and this other John they get a
cab and they're in this cab all together
and they're talking so they're gonna go
to jeans house first which was in this
neighborhood called Knights wood now
this taxi ride was 20 minutes long Jane
is talking to this guy he said his name
was John she said his last name sounded
like Templeton or simpleton
that's what he thought his name was she
said he's about in his late 20s about 29
years old very tall very slender light
reddish hair and this is a similar
description to the man that had been
seen with Jemima McDonald she said that
he was very polite and he was very
well-spoken that he was a little snotty
though little uptight yeah quoted from
the Bible
a lot he allegedly told them that night
clubs were dens of iniquity oh here we
go and he called them adulterers ho even
though because I guess because they were
out dancing even though they were
separated from their husbands they were
technically worse but they were
separated and you know so he talked
about all this kind of Bible issue now
so the cab stops in front of jeans house
and she gets out leaving her sister
Helen and this dude in the cab
alone taxi takes off Jean never sees her
sister again next morning Helens body
was found in a back garden of a flat on
Earl Street again only a hundred yards
away from her own house she had also
been raped strangled with her own
stockings constant overhand
scattered near the remains the person's
self was never found
she was also on her period the murderer
had tucked a sanitary napkin under her
arm and he had bitten her leg there was
a big bite mark I don't like so is he
walking them home and then attacking
them before they get there
prop yeah I'm thinking that's probably
what it is and that's probably what
happened in this they were both in a cab
together and it's probably like oh my
house is just here I'll get out with you
and then you have a situation where
they're they're all on the red yeah
which to me doesn't mean could it be
then under certain certain circumstances
if they're not on the Ragged let's and
go yeah he could be following people
home all the time right and then seeing
if they're on the rag right and then if
they say that they're on a rag or
something like that because I'm excited
it would seem weird like meeting
somebody in a bar and being like hey so
how's the Ritter's his fetish and then
like having a stranger like askew appear
on the ride especially in 1968 I feel
like that would be a little it's creepy
now there's got to be some kind of a
weird way that a dude can detect it yeah
I mean there's some kind of weird that
it's just way maybe he actually looks in
her purse while she's no he has any
passion she has those in there oh that's
a good idea
didn't think of that he does it well you
know her head has turned he somehow
looks and look her in her purse yeah
because it definitely does seem I mean
like I said that would be really random
if you just pick three he's in the bar
and they were all on their period that
must mean checks the purse first yeah
and if he finds napkins in there he goes
for if they have napkins he doesn't go
after that one yeah something like that
some it might be something that's
something that were taken for granted
he knows beforehand right so this killer
who they ended up calling Bible John
because of watching McLaughlin had said
about all the bible quotes and
everything like that they these are the
three canonical Bible John murders okay
although one of the main suspects for
this that you know they're not a hundred
percent sure but that it's that it
probably could be him is actually a
serial killer who got convicted for some
other [ __ ] later on and they think that
this is maybe some of his earlier crimes
and that guy's name was Pete
Tobin Peter Tobin is still alive
he's serving a whole life sentence in
Scotland for some [ __ ] he pulled much
later on now things pointing to maybe
him being Bible John the sexual assaults
and murders that he was convicted of he
actually wasn't convicted until 2006 and
the span of sexual assaults and murders
that they think was him span from 91 to
2006 but he was already a little bit
older in nineteen anyone older than
generally a serial killer would start so
they kind of think that maybe the Bible
John murders were like his early like
practice run tech murders so they did
think that Peter Tobin had lived in
Glasgow around 1968-1969
apparently he met his first wife at the
barrel Anne's ballroom right in 1969
after he met her he moved away so that
might have explained why there were only
three quote unquote Bible John murders
because he moved away with his first
wife now he was married three times to
all three of his wife said that he had
beat them and raped them on several
occasions also the interesting fact that
he was driven into violent rages by
women's menstrual cycles like it was a
weird thing that he had right all of his
wives said that or evidently so later on
there was something in 2006 the UK
police or whatever they started a thing
called operation anagram because they
figured look this Tobin dude is
suspected of so many crimes he committed
so many rapes and murders in this
particular period there have to be other
murders that he's associated with that
are unsolved yes so they did they had
this massive tax taskforce and
everything like that they said we're
gonna try and tie him to some of this
Sun salts it that looks similar to his
MO so while they were doing that they
actually got a DNA sample from Helen
buttocks stockings and they compared it
to his DNA but the results were
inconclusive the DNA that they got from
her stockings was too degraded so the
thing about it though even though it
does kind of sound like it's probably
him and I I'm kind of leaning toward it
maybe being him it should be no
that gene mcLaughlin Helen products
sister the one who rode in the cab the
killer
she said that's not him right although
like I said he was a lot older when he
got arrested and he did kind of look
like he had red hair and he did kind of
when he was young he did kind of look
like a lot of the paintings and [ __ ]
that were done of Bible John so it's
still possible that it was him also he
had he went by under a bunch of aliases
and one of his aliases was John simple
which sounds like simple Sonora term
Ronson which is what Jane McLaughlin
said his name was but like I said she
said I'm pretty sure that wasn't the guy
that was in this cab with us so who
knows she actually died in 2010 so there
that kind of line of inquiry is gone and
most of the DNA that they've got from
the Bible John burgers is not good
enough to compare with his DNA so the
Bible John cases may be part of
Templeton's s name yet sample 10 or
simple sin or whatever older Tobin's 7s
that's all about that meant those may be
Tobin murders they might be because that
actually sounds kind of more likely that
way the whole menstruation angle is
really just something to happen by
chance because there were other victims
that right we're not on it now if if
menstruation had something to do with
this you know modus operandi he would
have to know beforehand my explanation
is is while they're in the club he's
reaching into her purse in the darkness
beyond around inside her purse that
could be one or yet looking in there and
then if he finds napkins he targets or
he doesn't find no napkins he doesn't
maybe although it could just be
statistical might have been part of a
larger yeah murder spray and they're
just grouping these together because
napkins were involved yeah because these
three were almost identical and they
were all all the victims were taken from
the same place they were that's where
they were lasting and your witness may
have been drunk that may have been Tobin
she just maybe yeah i diem right and
like I said when he was convicted you
know he was convicted much later on he
was much older so it's you know it's
possible that she should
she didn't recognize them because maybe
he had her aged weird or something like
that yeah so operation anagram even
though it's not going full-throttle
right now he has actually been
exonerated of a few of the unsolved
murders that they thought were
associated with him but there are still
nine unsolved murders in the UK that
they think might have been him that
they're trying to tie him to you know
but the bible john murders are not
definitively them yeah and the weird
thing is that Helens the third victim
Helen Puttock her husband George he
seems to think that Helen Puttock was
killed by the Yorkshire Ripper Peter
Sutcliffe who we also did a show about
he was actually convicted of 13 murders
first one that they know of took place
in 1975 why does I think that though
see I'm not really sure and I don't
think the investigators are all that
into it either because of a bite mark so
I don't know the mo doesn't sound real
similar but for some reason he thinks
that but I don't think any investigators
are kind of down with that but again Ike
I'm kind of leaning toward it being
Bible John because the only reason to
not think that is because Jane
McLaughlin was like hey I wrote in the
cab with the dude I don't think it's him
but like I said that was a long time ago
right so everything else seems to point
to him and he sounds like you know he's
a piece of [ __ ] he's still alive like I
said he's still in a prison in Glasgow
but they're never letting his ass out
because yeah he was ultimately convicted
of three murders but they think he did a
[ __ ] ton of other ones so I guess we've
gone like kind of over again like we
have a min yeah not as much as I thought
we were but I think I got most of the
stuff in that I wanted to get in about
these two serial killers so hope you've
enjoyed this again extra long episode
about murders and movies and all the
usual digressions we usually take
getting tazed for Jesus and what's all
good it's all good it's all good so
remember if you liked the show remember
to Like share subscribe and share on all
your social media tell all your friends
and recommend us to other people who you
think may be into this kind of thing and
if you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
which is patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcasts or if you would rather give a
one-time donation through PayPal you can
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast word
calm and there's a link in the sidebar
to a PayPal account also remember to
check out our last movie review which
was phantasm and also check out our
t-shirts and tote bag that are available
on our zazzle store which is zazzle.com
slash 13 o'clock and that will do it for
episode 88 about Jack the stripper and
Bible Jon we will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]